le mois d'avril a commencé avec un
nouvel adhérent pour activity saint
quentin en yvelines a rejoint l' agence
d'insertion professionnelle le
territoire de saint quentin
c'est avec le territoire de la vallée de
la seine le territoire où il y à la fois
le plus grand nombre de bénéficiaires du
rsa mais aussi où il ya le plus grand
nombre d'entreprises et à dynamisme
entrepreneurial qui est très marquée
vd comme a fêté ses cinq ans pour
l'occasion l'institut installé à
versailles-satory organisait une journée
portes ouvertes avec ses 200 employés vd
comme réfléchit à une mobilité du futur
autour des véhicules électriques et
autonome ce drame a ému toute la france
mais aussi le monde entier la cathédrale
notre dame de paris a pris feu lundi 15
avril à 18h50 un symbole fort pour la
communauté catholique
je suis vraiment bouleversé par ça c'est
vraiment un symbole effectivement vous
vous employez le bon mot un symbole qui
est qui et qui est parti qui est parti
en fumée fin qui est et et l'émotion que
ça suscite chez moi c'est je crois
vraiment que c'est de la tristesse aussi
mais quelle quel gâchis quoi le
département des yvelines a rendu hommage
le 7 mai à ces soldats du feu 57 d'entre
eux ont reçu une médaille pour avoir
combattu l'incendié de notre dame de
paris avec la première biennale
d'architecturé de paysage la région ile
de france ouvrait ses portes à
versailles le 3 mai bape 3 leds pour
découvrir l'architecturé à travers des
lieux de patrimoine des colloques ou
encore des expositions
je voulais qu'on donne à voir à tous les
franciliens ce que le grand paris allait
être en 2030
côté sport le championnat national de
quidditch issu de la célèbre saga harry
potter s'est déroulée aux
clayes-sous-bois parmi les équipes les
aides le sentent le seul club yvelinois
dans cette discipline après trois ans de
travaux le musée du jouet de poissy a
rouvert ses portes le 11 mai 600 jouets
ont été rassemblés choisi par les 14000
de la collection du musée inauguré par
le ministre de la culture franck riester
fin mai une grève mondiale était
organisée pour le climat des
rassemblements ont eu lieu dans
plusieurs villes de france à saint
quentin en yvelines c'était une première
300 manifestants étaient présents selon
les organisateurs autre rassemblement le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines a accueilli deux manches de la
coupe du monde de bmx
deux cent soixante concurrents issus de
25 nationalités se sont affrontés
l'événement affiché complet lutter
contre les déserts médicaux une volonté
du département
le 14 juin se tenait l'inauguration de
la maison médicale d'aubergenville huit
professionnels de santé se partagent les
locaux d'ici 2020 de 20 établissements
de ce type couvriront le territoire
santé toujours les services des urgences
des hôpitaux en grève depuis trois mois
déclenchée notamment suite à une série
d'agressions ils demandent une hausse
des salaires et des effectifs mais aussi
de meilleures conditions de travail
une partie du personnel du centre
hospitalier de mantes-la-jolie étaient
en grève le mois de juin rime avec
baccalauréat pour les lycéens il a
débuté le 17 juin par la traditionnelle
épreuve de philosophie
ils étaient 70 1944 candidat dans les
yvelines pour les plus petits la
préoccupation n'est pas aux révisions
mais au jeu de construction multiples
située à chambourcy les bâtisseurs en
air propose aux enfants et leurs parents
de s'évader dans leur monde imaginaire
un concept unique en france et en europe
fin juin les pelleteuses sont rentrés en
action sur le chantier de démolition de
la piscine de maurepas malgré plusieurs
au cours d'une partie de l'opposition
qui souhaitait une réhabilitation
c'est bien une déconstruction puis une
reconstruction qui s'annonce